بالعوده الى شمال قطاع غزه معنا من مستشفى
شفاء في مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل
الغول اسماعيل رغم الانسحابات العديده
التي تمت في عده مناطق في شمال قطاع غزه
الى ان العمليات لا تزال دائره في مناطق
اخرى ولا يزال هناك تلك التداعيات
الانسانيه لما جرى طواله ثلاثه اشهر ما
التفاصيل نعم الانسحابات من منطقه شمال
قطاع غزه هذا لا يعني ان القصف الاسرائيلي
توقف على هذه المناطق فمنذ صباح هذا اليوم
استمر القصف الاسرائيلي بالطائرات المسيره
بالاضافه الى مدفعيه قوات الاحتلال التي
تطلق نيرانها ونيران رشاشاتها ونيران
مدفعيتها ما بين فينه واخرى صباح هذا
اليوم وقع خمس استهدافات ثلاثه من هذه
الاستهدافات في منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان
ومنطقه حي النصر هذه المناطق التي هي
تعتبر على تماس مباشر مع قوات الاحتلال
وكل من يحاول الاقتراب ال الى مناطق تواجد
قوات الاحتلال او الى اماكن نزوحهم هي
بعيده عن تواجد اماكن قوات الاحتلال لكن
هي بتماس مباشر للايضاح اما وقعت ثلاث
استهدافات كان حصيله هذه الاستهدافات
وسبعه شهداء فلسطينيين واصابه العشرات هذه
الاستهدافات كانت بمدفع قوه الاحتلال
وطائرات الاستطلاع ايضا استهدافات اخرى
وقعت استهداف في منطقه الصبره مما ادى الى
سقوط شهيدين في تلك المنطقه واستهداف اخر
في منطقه تل الهواء ادى الى سقوط ثلاث
شهداء باثر استهداف طائره استطلاع
اسرائيليه هذه الاستهدافات التي وقعت
ومجمل هذه الاستهدافات التي اسفرت عن عدد
من الشهداء وصلوا الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي
بالاضافه الى ذلك انتشال الكثير من
الشهداء وجثامين الشهداء من منطقه التفاح
والدرج ومنطقه شرق الشجاعيه حتى هذه
اللحظه الاهالي تحاول انتشال كل جثامين
الشهداء التي وقعت اثرى القصف الاسرائيلي
لكن كثير ايضا من هذه الجثث لا تصل الى
مجمع شفاء الطبي مما تضطر الاهالي الى دفن
هذه الجثث بسبب تحللها بالاضافه الى ظهور
الكثير او فوائح رائحه التي تحلل هذه
الجثه وظهور الديدان على هذه الجثه بسبب
التحلل بعد تركها لعده ايام بسبب القصف
الاسرائيلي ومنع قوات الاحتلال الوصول الى
هذه المناطق الان الاهالي لازالت تبحث عن
كثير من ابنائها الذين فقدوا اما بقصف
اسرائيلي او باعتقد اسرائيلي الحاله
الانسانيه بالانتقال الى الحاله الانسانيه
الحاله الانسانيه صعبه في مدينه غزه حتى
هذه اللحظه تحاول الطواقم الطبيه تشغيل
مجمع الشفاء الطبي الذي تاثر بشكل كبير
بعد احتلال قوات الاحتلال له وتدمير
الكثير من الاجهزه والمباني بعد ان تواجدت
قوات الاحتلال لما يزيد عن 15 يوما داخل
هذا مجمع بالاضافه الى ذلك الحاله
الانسانيه على مستوى المياه لا يوجد ابار
تضخ مياه سواء صالحه للشرب او غير صالحه
للشرب للاستخدام الشخصي في مدينه غزه سو
ابار بسيطه جدا وقليله جدا تحاول الفرق
والاهالي المتواجده في غرب مدينه غزه
وشرقها وشمالها وجنوبها او اماكن تواجد او
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال اعاده تشغيل هذه
الابار لكن تفتقر حتى الاهالي لادنى
المقومات من مولدات كهربائيه ووقود لهذه
المولدات لاعاده تشغيل هذه الابار وضخها
بشكل بسيط لحصول بعض الاشخاص فقط على
جالون مياه للاستخدام الشخصي اما عن
الغذاء فالحاله ماساويه جدا حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يدخل مساعدات من ايام طويله حتى
دقيق او معدات او مواد تموينيه اساسيه او
معلبات الحاله صعبه جدا في ظل عدم وجود او
دخول مساعدات الى مناطق شمال قطاع غزه
ايضا اسماعيل نلاحظ خلفك في الصوره ان
اعداد النازحين داخل مستشفى الشفاء لا
تزال على ما هي عليه هؤلاء لا يجدون اماكن
يذهبون اليها لازال الوضع رغم الانسحابات
لا يسمح لهم بالعوده الى اماكن دمرت
بالكامل نعم نعم لازالت اعداد النازحين في
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي كبيره جدا على
الرغم من محاوله الكثير من الاهالي العوده
الى منازلهم والتعايش مع الواقع الصعب
والدمار الكبير الذي حل في المناطق لكن
كثير من هذه الاهالي لا يوجد لها منازل
دمرت بشكل كامل من القصف الاسرائيلي الذي
استمر على قطاع غزه لما يزيد عن 90 يوما
هذه الاهالي حتى هذه اللحظه لا تج جد ماوى
سوى مجمع افاء الطبي والمدارس واماكن ال
نزوح المحيطه في هذا المجمع هي المدارس
الوحيده التي تاوي اداد كبيره من النازحين
مدينه غرب غزه اصبحت مدينه مكتظه بالسكان
بسبب عدم قدره الاهالي العوده الى منطقه
حي التفاح الذي دمر بشكل كبير جدا
بالاضافه لمنطقه حي الشجاعيه الذي شهد
الدمار كبير اما عن منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان
ومنطقه حي النصر هناك خطوره في تواجد
الاهالي فيضطر الاهالي عدم الرجوع الى
منازلهم هذه المناطق تشكل خطرا كبيرا بسبب
قصف الاحتلال المتواصل سواء المدفعي او ط
الاستطلاع فيبيت في هذه الاماكن التي
تعتبر شبه امنه علما ان قوات الاحتلال
قصفت من قبل اماكن تواجد النازحين ومدارس
اواء نازحين حتى هذا المستشفى تعرض لقصف
اسرائيلي بشكل مباشر لكن النسب الامان
مختلفه بشكل كبير جدا فيعتبر هذا المكان
او مستشفى الشفاء والمكان المحيط به امن
نسبيا بالنسبه للاهالي المتواجده في هذا
المكان من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه
مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول شكرا جزيلا
لك